los números de muertos y desaparecidos
continúan aumentando en esta crisis que
afecta particularmente a alemania en el
occidente del país pero que también se
evidencia ya en otros países europeos
como bélgica y los países bajos aquí en
alemania los esfuerzos están centrados
en lo más urgente en esas labores de
rescate en las zonas más afectadas pero
también ya está empezando a discutir en
los efectos a mediano y a largo plazo en
particular en las labores de
reconstrucción y de ahí que la canciller
alemana angela merkel está en contacto
con los ministros de finanzas y del
interior para determinar exactamente
cómo será esa ayuda una vez terminen las
labores inmediatas de rescate y también
se está empezando ya a discutir las
causas el impacto del cambio climático
un tema que está otra vez en el centro
del debate político aquí en alemania
cuando faltan pocos meses para las
elecciones federales que marcarán el
comienzo de una nueva era política aquí
en alemania